every business i have five companies now
we'll do a hundred million this year i
started every one of those companies
with no money zero money man just hustle
and grit and courage
[Applause]
i've called on people i didn't want to
be with i've done things i didn't want
to do okay it is not about doing what
you love it's about doing whatever it
takes
to make your dreams a reality to be
closed and stay closed if you're not
closed on your product if you're not
buying your own product why would you
expect anybody else to
man 400 bucks is a lot of money your
prospect says to you 400
do it
listen to me man you're 32 years old
you've been trying to save money for 20
years and you hadn't do it and do it now
i don't need anything special here i'm
not going to be empathetic
quit being stupid right to check
i don't know if the compliance guy likes
that or not
but i know this look if you believe in
what you're selling how many of you
believe in what you're selling
then close the deal
then close the deal okay learn to close
and you'll never be without work you'll
never be without money you'll have an
organization that is booming in
affluence
you'll have a pipeline full you'll have
appointments filled up
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how to
become a millionaire enjoy
group called me yesterday i'm actually
trying to do a deal with cnbc and the
guy says i'm interested i said good i'll
be there tomorrow call me back i'll be
i'm flying into new york tomorrow what
am i trying to do right now by the way i
was supposed to be here today
i'll fly into new york tomorrow i can be
there tomorrow mr ackerman okay how does
that work
i can't do tomorrow i was going to be
here anyway i'm trying to close the deal
let me close the deal i'll figure out
how to be in two places at one time
later
right you some of you in the room
they're like hey i can see it four
o'clock on tuesday right and the
customer says to you i'll see you at
four o'clock
let me look at my calendar like like
you're so busy
dude that is so old
that is so old and it's dishonest
[Music]
it's dishonest man
you want to see me tuesday four o'clock
i give you tuesday at four o'clock agree
to it
done
done i'll call you if something changes
if there's an earthquake between now and
next tuesday tuesday morning there's a
massive earthquake and i can't be there
you think everybody will understand
commit first they're gonna rest out
later close the deal right now fill your
calendar up your calendar's got the
devil all over it
white space on a calendar and you will
meet the devil
you don't need to die okay you go two or
three days without anything going on how
many of you start having doubts
you're in hell
oh my god this ain't gonna work for me
there's nobody coming in i'm not gonna
hit my target okay i know what i'll do
i'll lower my target
that's the devil doing that man that's a
criminal
never ever if you're taking notes never
lower a target
never lower a target never lower a
target your mom and dad would tell you
to lower a target a manager might tell
you to lower target be reasonable
[Music]
be reasonable with yourself
just bring it down a little bit no man
criminal products are created like that
a guy sees the girl that he wants that's
the girl
she says no he goes to another girl
right he gave up on his dream
if you're going to give up in your own
dream how are you going to build an
organization rule number two make
sacrifices with gary vaynerchuk
you don't want to go to college you
don't have to go to college you don't
want to be a doctor you don't have to be
a doctor right
but
that also means that if that's what your
parents want and that's what they're
willing to pay for
you can't be like hey mom you know how
you're going to give me 80 000 to go be
a doctor that that's what you want well
i don't want that i want to be a painter
so give me that 80 000 that's not how it
works
you have to leave that on the table that
money that infrastructure comes with
that ambition like if you want that
safety and that money well that means
you're going to be a lawyer if you want
to be a motorcycle racer that means
you're going to live in a studio
apartment with 19 friends
people ask the dumbest this kid the
other day is like gary vee but how do
you do this in the bay area it's so
expensive like you moved
you don't live in the bay area
you have a choice people like gary
what the [ __ ] like you're trying to pay
14 an hour how do you survive in new
york city i'm like you live in queens
and you take like like you can do
anything
you have options people aren't willing
to sacrifice
for what they want rule number three
believe with les brown how did you crawl
out from under the labels that people
were putting on you the easiest thing
i've done was to get out from under the
labels and to live the life that i live
the most difficult thing i've ever done
was to believe
that i can do it what's the difference
the difference is that when you don't
know what's impacting you
and it's it's something that that's
holding you down and you're not aware of
it the great anthropologist margaret
mead was in a restaurant in london
and and a guy was serving her and said
there's several americans here tonight
and she said is that right yes let me
know when you serve them dessert i'll
tell you exactly how many are here he
said oh you couldn't possibly
and so he came back and said okay i've
done it and
she got up and she walked around
and she came back and she said
they're around
25 here
and he looked at the roster how did you
know that say in america
we eat differently from you when we eat
a dessert you eat it from the crust
toward the tip
weeded from the tip toward the crust
when you eat a slice of pie how do you
eat yours i definitely have from the the
tip back to the crust for sure yeah okay
and so so there are things that when you
in my situation you live in a dominant
culture that is designed to destroy your
sense of self and your belief in
yourself and
and you have to learn ways in which you
can begin to connect with this power
that you have within yourself to handle
where you are
the key is to be constantly in a
perpetual process
of discovering the truth of who you are
and
fighting constantly to
look for ways in which you can escape
the inner conversation i speak to
audiences around the world and i and i
train speakers as well and i i tell them
that
when you speak
that there's a there's an objective that
you want to achieve when you speak to an
audience because how people live their
lives as a result of the story
they believe about themselves so
you as a speaker when you speak in this
program when people see you what you do
is distract dispute and inspire you
distract people from their current story
with your guests and the questions that
you ask through the process of the
ongoing questioning and the way in which
they respond and the things they have
learned you dismantle their current
belief system and inspire them to to
create a new chapter with their lives
and so but that's an ongoing process of
of constantly interrupting that
conversation what psychologists call
your self-explanatory style because life
is going to beat up on you in so many
ways and many things they come back you
know negative thoughts and and how you
feel about yourself
they don't die they they come back once
you stop doing the maintenance work on
your mind
listening to motivational messages going
to seminars and workshops spending time
quietly listening to the still small
voice within who am i really is this
really me am i giving my best uh am i
just reflecting what's around me because
all of these various things affect how
we show up in life also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four develop grit with
tom bilyeu if grit is as important as we
say it is
sustained interest over time that's
really what grit is
and a lot of people talk about in fact
the title of my speech is supposed to be
about how you develop a passion which we
will talk about in a little bit
but this is going to be one of those
things
when you have passion
one of the things that comes out of that
is you've got the ability to sustain
your interest over time do the hard
things
do the hard things
i can't emphasize that one enough
put yourself in uncomfortable situations
just to find the mental tactics that
you're gonna need
to deal with
the hard things it's getting those
tactics who knows the stanford
marshmallow test
all right for those of you that don't
this is one of the most breathtaking
examples of the human condition in the
stanford marshmallow test they bring in
i don't know five or six years old they
bring them in and the person in the
white lab coat says here's a marshmallow
i'm gonna go out of the room for a
minute i'll be back in just a few
minutes if you wait till i come back
i'll give you a second marshmallow so
essentially double your money
not bad
now what the kid doesn't know is
researchers never coming back and all
they want to know is how long will you
wait before you eat the marshmallow some
kids have literally gobbled it up before
they even get to the door
other kids are like singing to
themselves putting their head down
getting up dancing around the room some
of them bite like the underside and try
to put it back so you can't see
and here's what's scary
they followed those kids for 25
years
and based solely on
the length of time they were able to
wait before they ate the marshmallow
predicted their level of success in
school
predicted their level of success in the
job market the people who waited the
longest got into the best schools got
the best grades went on to have the
highest paying jobs
just your ability to delay gratification
your ability to find tactics that work
to get your mind off something
there's no greater control than control
over one's self
anybody here ever done a three day water
only fast
not intermittent fasting
three days
do it
you will learn something about yourself
and it will be profound and what you're
gonna learn
is that your body is
manipulative
and i did a three-day fast just a couple
weeks ago
and i had the flu right before so there
were cough drops laying around
and every time i walked by those cough
drops my brain was like eat one
and i was like
like
you know i'm fasting
and i literally couldn't believe like
how consistently every time i walk by
those damn cough drops that my body like
gave me this really intense impulse
and that's when i realized like the
notion that there are multiple voices in
your head by the way is very very real
and i will give you one quick example
who knows what the corpus callosum is
all right the corpus callosum is a thick
bit of tissue that connects the left and
right hemisphere of your brain if you
sever that you will get people that have
literal multiple personalities one in
the right one on the left some of the
most intriguing stuff is one of them
will be devoutly religious and the other
will be devoutly atheist
in the same brain and you can talk to
them differently
it's absolutely crazy
but the multiple voices notion is real
there are multiple
factions if you will pieces that your
brain is broken up into and by the way
you have the equivalent of a cat's brain
in neurons just in your digestive tract
so the whole notion of gut instinct
think of all the cool cats can do
and you've got that
in your digestive tract neurons
it's literally the same material that
your brain is made out of is in your
digestive tract utterly fascinating so
we have all these competing things that
we want
but inside if you think of that
overwatch
that one person that's you that's meant
to say i have goals
and i'm going to act in accordance with
my goals i'm never going to sell out
what i want most for what i want right
now i wanted a cough drop right now but
i wanted to get on the other side of a
three-day fast and say i did it
and i wanted that more
and in learning what your tools and
tactics are so for me i welcome hunger
like an old friend and i literally
people must think i'm schizophrenic
because you'll walk into the room and
i'll literally be like pinching and
poking at my fat
going
hunger thank you i'm so glad you made it
back it is so good to see you i'm glad
you're here i know that you're oxidizing
my fat i'm very grateful for that so
thank you and in doing that i reframe it
not as something that is unwanted or
painful but as something that is doing
exactly what i want it to do
and learning those mental tactics that's
the game
learning those mental tactics that's the
game that's how you're going to get good
at whatever it is you want to do if you
want to start a business learning how to
deal with your employees is absolutely
critical but let me tell you right now
if you lash out emotionally your
employees will lose respect for you
but it's just like the cough drop moment
now if somebody had seen me walk by the
cough drop they wouldn't know that i had
it literally had to
stop myself from lunging at a cough drop
they didn't know that because i have
control of myself
i've practiced things like that i do
three-day fast i do what i call bright
lines
so i have a bright line
during the week
i don't eat my second meal before 11 30.
under any circumstance
my wife one time brought my food 30
minutes early i was preparing for an
episode it was so sweet of her
but i don't eat before 11 30 under any
circumstance so the food literally sat
on my lap
smelling so good
and i was so hungry
and i said hunger thank you so much
for showing up because you're giving me
the opportunity to prove to myself
what a badass i am
because i'm going to smell how delicious
you are knowing my stomach is grumbling
and tying itself in knots because i want
to eat so badly
and i'm not going to
and in those moments you earn
credibility with yourself
i hate working out
absolutely despise it it's why i do it
first thing in the morning
and the reason i hate it the weights are
heavy
and your muscles start burning when you
get to the supposed good reps
so that just seems backwards
so it is not in any way shape or form
fun for me
but i earn credibility with myself
because it is something that i don't
like
i earn credibility with myself showing
up every day and it also reminds me how
much i can transform my body it's very
easy for me to show you my before and
after picture i used to be 60 pounds
heavier it's very easy for me to show
you when i was heavy and then show you
six pack abs you get it
but what you don't see is the body's
just a reflection of the mind
what really happened
was i changed my mind and i had garnered
skills i had garnered tactics the things
that allowed me to not eat the coffee
drop were the things that allowed me to
not eat the things that i wanted to not
have a bowl of ice cream to not indulge
in things that are
wonderfully delicious but instead ask
myself what are my goals and then back
in with my behaviors rule number five do
difficult things with robin sharma how
do we practice getting braver what does
it mean to be braver and then how does
that end up being useful for us
what terrifies you most go directly
there
because discomfort is simply
growth in wolf's clothing
um
well yeah i mean the last chapter
is uh i don't want to give too much away
but it's it's um an experience i live
you know it's it's nelson mandela's
prison cell
have you been to robin island i haven't
but i am beyond obsessed with nelson
mandela so i know the story very well
you know i i i'd encourage you to go
because
standing in that in that cell
feeling
the sensations
will transform you at a soul level as
well as hard set levels so how do we
become more brave well
i went over to
nelson mandela's prison cell and i stood
there and i was shocked he didn't even
have a bed and he was in there for 18
years
then
i went over to the limestone quarry
and i saw where nelson mandela spent 10
years chipping away at stone to break
his spirit because they threw the stones
away
and then i saw the showers where this
elderly statesman would shower while the
young guards would laugh at him and then
in the book i talk about a true fact
where
he was asked on robben island to dig a
grave and he he
got in the grave
thinking he was going to die and the
prison guards urinated on
and my point is simply this when nelson
mandela was released from prison
after 27 years of total incarceration
the he invited the prosecutor who was
seeking the death penalty to dinner
and he invited the prison guard who kept
him in prison for 18 years on robben
island
to his inauguration as president of
south africa and he was asked
why would you do that he said because
if i didn't i'd still be in prison
and my point is to lead and to become a
great hero
or an everyday hero
the doorway is through embracing our
suffering and doing difficult things i
think pleasure
has been promoted too much in our
society like no great
tight enough industry no legendary
cellist
no great athlete you know the great ones
all understand that suffering is the
price
of greatness so
how do we become braver you you do the
difficult things that you don't feel
like doing but you know have the payoff
rule number six stop listening to bad
advice with dean graziosi the other
thing is bad advice
right we get
our single friends telling us how to run
our relationships our broke friends
telling us what to do with our finances
but we give them credit and sometimes
it's family members who are unqualified
that think they're protecting you
but we take that i mean who in here has
ever had a thought an idea or an
invention that you wanted to get out to
the world that you knew would help
somebody and then who in here had
somebody say no that's already been
thought of oh you probably got to get a
patent oh get on tv that takes two money
that's stupid you're not gonna get on tv
and just one of the things they said
made you go um maybe not and then what
happened two years later
your stuff was on tv and someone else
was making a boatload of money right or
wrong but that happens in every area of
our life with relationships but we allow
that guidance we allow that even if you
think you're strong even just a little
nugget of that can turn you in a
direction where you go well maybe next
week maybe next year you put it off and
it's gone
get advice from people who are doing it
at a higher level take the advice you
know you want to play tennis play with
someone who played at the highest level
possible not your aunt because she
watches tennis on tv right
i tell this story really quick this is a
true story
my
one of my biggest infomercials was a
book called uh be a real estate
millionaire sold over a million copies
of that book and i did a show i don't
know if anybody's ever remember it it
was a show i did direct the camera it
was one of the first
infomercials where i didn't have a host
i didn't have fancy graphics i just had
a message i wanted to deliver and i
talked for a half hour straight to wreck
the camera no script and let me tell you
i'm going to give you the back story
real quick i was in utah doing a small
mastermind with about 15 people who
spent a lot of money to spend a couple
days with me and as i'm going around the
room with them
when i'm getting to them i'm realizing
why they're not going to the next level
of life it was all because of the advice
of people in their lives some of the
time it was their husband at home their
wife their parents their relatives so
i'm going around the room like the bad
advice going on in their lives is
crippling them and i was i was like i
was pissed i'm like i need to i need to
solve this so i called my team some of
them are here i'm like i'm flying in
from utah when i land i want to shoot a
new show and we were we were in the
middle of building a new studio the
studio wasn't set up so we just
literally they grabbed the bookshelf
they just stuck a whole bunch of books
on it i remember i had a sports jacket
at the office i had shorts on and
flip-flops and a sports jacket no one
knew i even put a tie on i sit and i
just rambled to the camera for a half
hour and i didn't make it a big fancy i
had my book in my hand i said oh by the
way guys if you want to get my book call
the number at the bottom of the screen
then i go back to sharon but in this
reason i'm telling the story is i'm so
in the moment and not paying attention
you know when you're in flow and you
barely know what's coming out of your
mouth i get to a point i said listen
you have to watch the outside influences
and the bad advice you have no idea how
much it affects you and you can't learn
from people who don't know how to do it
or failed you think you can learn from
someone who failed they only know how to
do it wrong and then they're biased
about it because they got hurt in the
middle of it so i'm telling this on tv
and i say take my parents for example
they've been married nine times when i
want marriage advice they are the last
people i ask they suck at it
completely forgot i said that didn't
even know i said that and then the show
gets edited we put it out it was the
biggest show i had ever done it was
running listen to this there's no
exaggeration every minute of every day
seven days a week for 18 months
it sold 150 million dollars worth of
books and courses i'm not saying that
for an applaud i'm saying that because
about three months in it's on everywhere
everybody's calling my parents
so three months later my mom i this is
no i'm not going to exaggerate this to
it even a nickel i pick up my mom calls
i'm like hey mom i'm in a great mood my
show's doing good we're changing lives
my book's flying off the shelves
my mom just said really
and i said what's up mom she said really
i said mom hey what's up she says
do you know no one in my family knows
i've been married five times until now
she said and her great her aunt dorothy
who she calls her aunt dot she said aunt
dot nearly had a heart attack
it's her godmother so i i apologized and
i'm not kidding you i bought her a brand
new car the next day is an apology and
i've been buying her a new car over 18
months since then because of that but
that's how serious i am the fact of the
matter is my parents it's like my
parents when they were going through
they're both unhappy my my mom
especially not not my dad he he just
engaged and he just broke it off and
he's 80. don't ask
i have no idea where this came from like
but my parents the way they were with
marriages it'd be like you get a new car
and you know when you're really excited
it's got the new car smell you're
excited about it my parents were the
type with marriages that they'd be in
the car to be amazing and they're going
down the road and they hit a pothole oh
i'm getting out it's terrible
did you see that pothole it was at least
four inches deep
so that was my example but
but do you think my both my parents
liked to give me marriage advice
of course they did what was their
reference point
right they were so but i'm only i'm only
pushing so hard on that because
everybody in this room is here because
you want more growth more personal you
already have filters up you already are
different than most of people around you
you're already crazy for being here for
jumping on a plane and following the the
you know you're drinking the kool-aid i
mean i get it
you're the different ones
you get it you're drinking the kool-aid
but you have to realize that bad
advice those outside influences you have
to have a barrier so you can work on you
and rule number seven the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
do one more hour per day with brandon
burchard one hour more per day
on my core three
okay i begin this every year i go okay
first move i know i need to identify
what are the core three things right now
that have been bringing me results this
year
the core three things so as an example
because i'm an entrepreneur like many of
you guys are in my business i go okay
what are the three primary revenue
drivers we have right now
because just like you if you're in
marketing you probably tested a lot of
things throughout the you know the early
part of the year the spring even early
part of summer
so my question is what's been working
and i mean
absolutely working what are the three
absolute best things that are working
for you
in your business
or your career or your personal life if
you're not employed or not self-employed
like what's absolutely the three things
that are so working for you
i want you to know what those three
things are
and overall i want you to give an hour
every day more
to a focus of one two or three all three
of those things
so let me give you an example right now
in in my business right one of my core
three
is our book funnel
like so for me as you guys know as an
author and a trainer when i sell books
that's good for the business we sell
books then people want online courses
then they want to come to our seminars
then someday they might join our program
like we're doing here at our live events
or our masterminds or they might hire us
for coach or they might hire me for
speaking but the book is a big core
three for the business right and so
right now i go okay i need every single
day
the rest of this year
to give more time to that thing
every day not on a wednesday not on a
set like every day i need to check in
the numbers create a new ad
flip out a page i need to lead my team
better on it something every day
for that one thing
make sense
so if you got three things what i want i
want an hour
more so that mean might be in 20 minutes
20 minutes you know and you know 20
minutes
so you're given 20 minutes more each day
or maybe you just choose one
and you're gonna give that an hour more
a day but it's basically this
one more work hour of the day focused on
one of the core three
got it
write it down
and this for you i want you to start
this
today
today if that means you're watching this
in munich germany and we finish this
tonight and you stay stay up one more
hour i'm like cheers man do that but
it's like today for those of you who are
here in the u.s in this time zone i'm
like
today
one more hour on focusing i often call
the the core three or the needle movers
the primary three things that are
working i need an hour more from you a
day for the rest of the year
and you will thank me
for the next decade you're like oh my
god brandon because what happens is and
you know this you're getting caught up
in distraction and so right now people
are relaxed days ago
and they're not focused on the right
things
so i want you to think where are you
distracted i want you to clear out the
distractions i want you to say the core
three things in my business are
and i need you to give an hour or more a
day on those
that's it if you'll start that now
and you'll punch in that hour more
every day until thanksgiving i promise
your christmas will be unbelievable
i think entrepreneur is going to solve
every problem i think whatever problem
there is in the world entrepreneurs are
going to be the ones to solve it and
there's definitely a place for
government and everything else but i
just defaulted thinking it's us it's
entrepreneurs we're going to do it we
see a problem we want to fix it be the
change you want to see in the world and
and that's really at the crux of a
successful business when people ask me
how do you make money as an entrepreneur
well you solve a problem with something
that you love doing if you are solving
somebody else's problem that they're
struggling with you can get paid to do
it and if you love doing that thing then
that's how you start having a business
right that can have success long term
sustainable if you
solve a problem but you don't love doing
it you're going to end up burning out
phasing out people will be better than
you at it it won't be sustainable
because you don't love the thing and if
you just love the thing
but you're not solving a problem then
you've got a hobby right if you love
doing something but it doesn't solve
anybody's problem you've got a hobby and
it could be fulfilling and enriching for
the soul but that's not a business it's
in that combination of what solves a
real problem that you enjoy doing that's
how you start to make money i think one
of the biggest problems though for
entrepreneurs is we don't know what the
problem is we think we know what the
problem is but we don't know what the
problem is especially when it's for
ourselves we think that we know what our
problems are but we don't actually know
our problems because we're too in the
thing have you ever noticed how it's
easier to point out somebody else's
problems like you should be doing this
you know what's wrong with this business
they should be doing that but it's
harder to look at ourselves and say
here's the biggest problem that i'm
facing right now at least i find this as
a challenge um i'm sitting here at
genius network this is a
what is it's a mastermind it's a success
circle
of people who are
having seven eight nine figure
businesses and they meet once a month to
help each other out and one of my
favorite exercises is when you
basically go down and it's called hot
seat and you think about what your
biggest problem is and they put you in
groups and then you're explaining your
problem to the other people in your
group and you get suggestions you get
feedback and these are all you know
peers people who've done
equally or maybe even more things than
you have and it's great to get at least
i think a fresh perspective and so
yesterday um one of the members that i
was in that group with
he came up and he said i
my biggest problem is i need to have
more structure in my life i need to be
more intentional with my time i'm too
all over the place i'm i'm too
you know creative and and
and you know it's got me this far but
it's not going to be the thing that gets
me to the next step i need to have more
discipline and schedule
and the first
uh person started giving him some advice
and and uh she was telling him how she
sets her schedule and gives some
feedback and
the thing they just kept throwing
flowing through my mind and when it came
to me to give advice i just asked the
question do you even want this
you're like do you even want this
and
he's like
it feels it sounds like prison
as a guy that you've been in prison
before so he knows what that feels like
it's like when i when i think about it
when i talk about it feels like i'm in
prison
and
that is
a classic case for a lot of
entrepreneurs who want freedom who are
creative who want to be out
like creativity is messy
creativity is messy and so you can't be
productive and you can't be efficient if
you're being creative and knowing a
little bit about him said dude that
that's not your problem
see this is where we got cut up in our
own in our own traps and our own
thinking because we can't self-diagnose
very well we often need people to help
us so
when he says
my problem is i'm not being intentional
with my time and i'm wasting a lot of
time i need to be more structured that's
not his problem
in fact what he needs to do is the exact
opposite he needs to be spending more
time in his zone of genius he needs to
be spending more time being creative he
needs to have the freedom to spend three
days
swimming with alpacas if that's the
thing that is in his mind because it's
gonna lead to some awesome new creation
that if you take a creative genius like
he is and you force him into a structure
and a schedule then he's going to end up
in a prison like he said and and
just imagine you know if he lives a week
like that versus a month like that
versus six months like that versus a
year like that the more he's trapped in
that prison the less effective he's
actually going to be he might be really
efficient and productive
for a short amount of time but he's
going to end up hating his life and he's
not going to birth any new
creative things into the world and he's
out of his own of genius
and so
his real problem is he doesn't have the
person on his team to be that number two
to take things over
and he hasn't assigned that person
the responsibilities or given them
permission to be able to to run with
those things he's already built the
seven-figure business so it's not like
i'm i'm talking to somebody who's brand
new startup doesn't know what he's doing
right this is a already successful
entrepreneur but again it's easy to spot
the problems in other people's
businesses and other people's lives and
sometimes in our own and so
the problem
was different than the problem that he
thought he had
and solving the right problem by getting
some perspective
will change his life just as i was
talking and expressing
what i thought about him you could see
these starts to come alive and at the
end he's like
i feel that this is the guy who's really
in tune with with body and energy and
he's like
i feel that he's like touching his heart
you know as he's doing it and like thank
you and what a gift and so
we solved the right problem
and so
if you are struggling right now
i think one of the best things you can
do is is one model success so go find
the people who've done what you're
trying to do and see what resonates you
know bill gates save my business even
though i've never met him because i had
a software company and i looked at
bill gates who started a software
company and that's
what i modeled and it started to work
but i think even more importantly
if you're really struggling right now is
to be around other people who might be
able to help
because you're around some people even
if you're a shy and introverted like me
you saw people some people around you
the problem is they can't tell you what
the problem is you know their their
version of the problem is something you
don't want to hear i don't believe in
negative or toxic people i don't think
that's what's going on but
they're
you know hurt people hurt people so they
could be in a lot of pain they could be
hurt they have a different perspective
one that you you don't want their life
you don't respect their opinion on the
thing that you're asking about
and so you're just probably around the
wrong people
and to be able to change that to shift
that to you might be able to i mean this
group here one group was twenty five
thousand dollars a year to be in the
others a hundred thousand dollars to be
in so
you may not be able to afford to to go
to a group like that but you don't need
it because the most you don't need it
yet you know the most important thing is
momentum to start building to start
being around more positive optimistic
happy people who you do respect you can
do something with i made a group called
move it makers and every two weeks we
meet and these are people who want to be
thought leaders who want to share want
to help have a message on their heart
and need to get out to the world and
it's great to be around me and i teach
and i share and i give my perspective
but the biggest learning i think
honestly is by them being connected to
each other by them doing challenges and
projects together by them interviewing
each other on their channels so that
they're not alone and they have people
to talk to and connect with and feel
like
like this matters and there's some
momentum because
whatever you want to do the people
around you don't understand it right if
you're an entrepreneur you're a little
bit crazy it's awesome like high five i
love you celebrate but you're a little
bit crazy and different and the people
around you don't understand you and some
people might just be supportive just not
know what to tell you and other people
might be straight out negative and say
stop doing that be practical be
realistic go get a job go to school go x
go live a safe life and you don't want
that life
and so you need to start being around
the people collect good people who
support you who cheer you on who believe
in you who say that you can do things
who still push you but in a positive
loving way forward as opposed to a
negative way down that makes you feel
like things are possible and so how do
you find those people well
you could join a group right i mean
genius network uh might be a fit for you
if you've got a big budget movement
makers might be a fit for you if you're
trying to be a thought leader but
but
actively look for people actively look
for events and conferences and groups
even if it's a free meetup group at the
beginning like actively look to be
around
people who are close to you
or online groups that you can join but
that are around the same interests of
you because when you're around the
people who are trying to do the same
thing that you are trying to do even if
they haven't quite done it yet it's not
only mentoring where they've done it and
they're showing you the ropes even if
it's they're trying to do it and you're
trying to do it to be around people who
are ambitious who want to chase down
their dream and goals and achieve
something try to make something of their
lives if you're around those people it
will just fill you with more energy
it will fill you with more energy and
make you feel like hope is possible
that'll be my immediate action item to
yes have the environment
pay attention to who you subscribe to on
youtube and who you follow on instagram
and the books that you're reading and
the content you're consuming does it
lift you up does it make you feel better
and belief and give you
hope and strategies and tactics and what
that should do and look at your circle
you know you're with the right people
and if not then just don't don't
don't make it some big thing did you
have to go join this giant group that's
super expensive
just start with
who can i who can i talk to right now
you know who's trying to do this thing
with me too
who's even at my level
that i can build and grow and learn with
and if you just switch your mindset to
start to look to start to search to go
to google and type in your city and look
for groups or to think about the
industry you want to be in like how to
be a thought leader or how to be a
xyz whatever it is that you are in
whatever your business is and to find
groups of people who are doing it you
know you want to be a
toastmasters for speakers or whatever it
is there's a group
to just join
and try it
because man when you're around people
who are doing things
it just breathes so much more life
energy and momentum into your mission my
key to being productive is doing
different things on different days
different activities different energy
states on different days if you feel
like
you're getting to the end of the day or
getting to the end of the week and
you're working like crazy like you were
working you you were not sucking off
you're working like crazy
and yet nothing seemed to happen has
have you gotten there it's like i did so
much work this week
and yet i've moved very
little towards actually accomplishing my
goals if that's you
the way to change it is to realize that
you're flipping between energy states
too much and you're not you're not
tapping into your true productivity so
let me share with you what i do and
hopefully that gives you some value to
planning your schedule in your life as
well
different tasks on different days i'll
break down for you what i do every day
of the week
monday is my mentoring day mondays are
the days where i spend mentoring my team
and i've got 37 people on my team
there's a bunch of people who have
invested into as well in their companies
and monday i just spend the whole day
talking to them all i have to worry
about is mentoring the people on my team
tuesday is youtube day so today i'm
filming on a tuesday i don't know what
day this video is being released but
it's a tuesday for me filming all i have
to worry about on a tuesday is making
youtube content
and
why it's so productive these days is
because it takes a while to make the
first video it takes a while to do the
first call takes a while to get momentum
going but once you get the momentum
going
it's easier to stain the momentum then
if you switch to something else it takes
a lot longer to get into that momentum
so quick example it's youtube day for me
it took me 15 minutes to get ready for
the first video and not get ready like i
have to do my hair
get ready just emotionally get ready
mentally get get ready not procrastinate
get ready to bring the energy and have
the right vibe and feel good enough and
and all of the stuff it takes took me 15
minutes to get ready and then the first
video
[Music]
it takes it takes a while to get the
mojo going and then after the first
video the second one is better and the
third one is better this is my fourth
one recording is better and now it's
easier to go right and so in the time it
takes me to make one video the first
video i could then in that same amount
of time go make three or four videos
in immediate
intermediate
i want to say sequential that's not a
word success in succession
in immediate succession
sick whatever
after i can make three or four more
videos right after while i'm in that
same vibe so same thing for you whatever
vibe you're feeling if you can stay in
that energy zone instead of switching if
i did youtube video then writing a book
then doing a phone call that meant for
my team then
you're just bouncing around too much and
there's high high high energy switching
costs that then keep you unproductive
then this is i mean a huge unlock
because when you can figure out how to
chunk your time like this
brain fog goes away productivity
dramatically increases you you suddenly
have a lot more free time as well to do
whatever you want to do nina is back
she's in the house
we are at nina's acupuncture let me put
my seatbelt on as we
well as we get ready to go
so tuesday's youtube day and i spend the
whole day making videos wednesday's
project day and on project day i focus
on whatever projects i want to work on
and
it's
i wake up in the morning i look at what
i want to work on today and it's a it's
a lot more of a creative day tuesdays
and thursdays are very intense
productive days wednesday is a
free-flowing day which is not very
productive but very creative what i had
to understand is creativity is messy and
creativity is not productive
so judge myself harshly when i was
working on a new project and it would
take me a long time and i felt like i
got nothing done
that's okay creativity is not meant to
be
efficient
so you won't be efficient on your
creative days on your creative tasks it
won't be efficient for you
but that's okay and i think you need to
have creative time built into your
calendar because if you're only doing
things that are productive you're gonna
burn out you're gonna hate your life and
you're going to feel
limited you ever get bored of your own
business you get bored of the things
you're doing well there's not enough
creative time planned into your week
when do you get time to work on new fun
things that maybe pay off maybe don't
pay off when you have time to work on
that well you don't okay so
that's when people have mid-life crisis
or burnout or want to throw it all away
or quit or stop doing this thing and so
i think you have to have some highly
productive days where you're really
working on achieving the goals that you
know i have to get these things done and
then you have to have some creative days
where you get to focus on whatever
projects you want that you're not
judging yourself harshly for being you
know not very efficient creativity is
messy it's designed to be that way and
you need to have some creative days in
your calendar or you will get tired of
your business and hate your life so
that's wednesday wednesday's creative
day project day thursday is public
facing day and thursdays
i'm
usually starting the day with either
movement makers or brand lytics and i'm
i'm introverted and shy and that doesn't
come across in these videos but i am and
it takes me a while to to
get into the zone of
being around other people
[Laughter]
so on thursdays i start with my family
and movie makers are my community of
thought leaders are trying to build
their business and get their message to
the world and brandlytics is my
community of people on youtube who want
to build their youtube channel up
specifically and want the advice to to
grow and create and so i start my
thursdays with them because it's
it's family it's safe it's friendly it's
warm and it makes me feel like what i do
matters and is important
and then the rest of thursdays
interviews and podcasts and
zoom calls and just all day spreading
the message
spreading the message you know what we
got believed to put out there and it's
easy to go off and do those things now
because i just came from movement makers
or brand lytics
so i'm already in the in the zone of
sharing and creating and impacting and
seeing smiles and so i carry that energy
into my next interview on my next
podcast and the next thing that i'm
doing so if i'm booking
to be on other people's shows even from
booking for my own show thursdays it's
always on a thursday it's always on a
thursday it's always on a thursday and i
have five-minute breaks in between so
it's usually 25 minutes
uh or 55 minutes and then five-minute
break and then on to the next one on to
the next one and so it's really easy and
all of a sudden it's seven o'clock and
what happened to today i don't know but
amazing things happened because you're
all in that energy and you know do tons
of different shows and episodes and
again so much easier to be in that in
that one zone than to then go make a
youtube video or then go and write my
book or then you know book writing was a
creative project so it's on a wednesday
i took me an hour just to get into
remembering what i did yesterday or last
week on my book right so if you only
give yourself an hour to write the book
that would be absolute waste of time
because it took me an hour to remember
where i left off last time
so that's thursday public facing day
friday is ceo day so that's what i need
to do to grow my business you know what
what are the big projects instead of
working in my business work on the
business so wednesdays work in the
business on creative projects friday is
if i'm going to be the ceo of my
business
what does that look like what do i need
to be doing because if you're an
entrepreneur you're you're the ceo
you're probably the janitor as well if
you're a one-person show
and we have to do a lot of things to
drive the business forward we have to be
in our business we don't have a giant
team yet even at 37 people i do a lot of
work in the business
as opposed to only just being the ceo
and just managing and
truthfully i like being in the business
i like like making videos like this is
not ceo time this is me
being in the business but i like it you
know i think i think people who uh often
just be the ceo if you're
entrepreneurial
and there's no projects you're working
on uh you you grow distant from the
business you don't enjoy it so
we all need time in our calendar every
week to focus on being the ceo and now i
spend all my fridays doing it at the
beginning
uh i just started with two hours so two
hours in my calendar okay this is my ceo
time and i blocked it off and i made it
important and when i started doing that
i started seeing more results in my
company uh saturday we applied to the
weekends too saturday is fun days so
saturday spending time with nina doing
whatever you know going it's starting to
get warm here in canada you can see you
know the grass finally green so if we're
going for a hike or trying out a
restaurant or going to a
street festival or just something fun
sunday is family at midday so all of the
stuff that we have to do to
manage the family you know go grocery
shopping
fold laundry clean up the house
family admin kind of stuff that's on a
sunday and then repeat the next day so
again quick summary monday is mentoring
day tuesday is youtube day wednesday's
project day thursday
is public facing day friday ceo day
saturday fun day and sunday is family
admin day
and that fits my life you know that's a
calendar for my life it won't photocopy
perfectly over to yours but the key is
to chunk your time and think about what
is a balanced life look like for me
so that
i'm happy i'm creative i'm productive
i'm moving closer to becoming the person
that i want to be
and
if you can't control
your calendar fully maybe you have a job
maybe you have other responsibilities
maybe you're still stuck doing some
things you don't want to do that's cool
don't don't stress out and worry about
oh i can't i can't completely control my
day i can't have a
youtube day
okay don't worry about it you have some
controllable time focus on the control
of the time you have and just be more
intentional with it
so that you're not wasting time
scrolling through instagram posts or
youtube videos mindlessly that that
you're
you're there with intention and you're
gonna
you have so many you have a certain
amount of controllable hours i think
part of the advantage of being an
entrepreneur is we have a lot more
controllable hours right if you're a
full-time entrepreneur you get the
control sure we have to you know
be uh
be responsive to our customers but we
don't have a boss
and we get to choose when we show up and
we get to choose what our calendar looks
like and that's part of the allure of
being an entrepreneur is that freedom
but if you're not completely there yet
you still have controllable hours when
you get home from work to the time you
go to bed when you wake up to the time
you go to work and then on weekends you
have controllable hours
be more intentional with them
and decide
what is the life
that you want to live that'll come down
to than the habits that you're executing
on daily which comes down to your
calendar
and when you can chunk similar tasks
together
when you can stay in the same energy
zone instead of switching between a
million different tasks every day
it allows you to be more productive it
allows you to be more effective it
allows you to be happier
and it allows you to get a lot closer to
your goals you don't have to stay stuck
when you come up with a great idea that
in your heart you know this is the thing
that i want to do and then almost
instantly all the negative voices come
in your head as to why you can't do it
and why someone like you will never be
able to do this thing that keeps you
stuck keeps you small keeps you
frustrated keeps you knowing that you're
capable of more and being too afraid to
go take the action
and until you can break that pattern
of negative self-talk
nothing will happen
and so we're going to fix that in this
video i think as soon as we come up with
ideas
it's not even our friends it's not even
the people around us it's us it's us
telling ourselves that we suck that we
can't do it that we're not good enough
that we're not keepable that it's not
gonna happen
we'd land into
procrastination mode and you can call
yourself a perfectionist it has to be
perfect
but perfectionism is still just fear
just fear just fear that you're not good
enough feel that it won't work out fear
of being seen fear of not being seen
and it keeps you stuck
when i procrastinate on things even like
making videos
yeah i've made i don't know how many 12
000 13 000 14 000 videos some crazy
number of videos and yet every time
before i sit down to make the videos i
procrastinate a little bit
in today's filming session
i'm here at uh my wife's acupuncture
clinic
she's inside getting her acupuncture
done i joined her sitting in the car
and it probably took me
15 minutes
to get into
the zone i know i'm gonna make the
videos i've developed the identity that
i'm gonna get get it done but i'm i'm
worried i want i want the videos to be
good i wanna i
don't wanna embarrass myself don't wanna
let myself down don't wanna let you down
fear of disappointing people is my my
biggest fear i don't want you to feel
like this is wasting your time you ever
had these thoughts you know like you
want to do something and then you want
it to be good and you don't want to
disappoint people and so you him and you
ha and you procrastinate and then and
then all of a sudden the day's gone you
haven't done anything you know how does
that happen so i try to keep it to 10
minutes 15 minutes today's a little
longer i'd usually be like 5-10 minutes
took a little bit longer 15 minutes
today to get into
to get into the zone and you know what
happened the next thought was
uh what if i just check uh check and see
how my team is doing and and
because i want to feel valuable and
because i want to feel like i'm doing
something productive i want to get out
of the discomfort of not filming videos
and go check in on my team because that
would make me feel more productive like
no no no
just sit with it
we gotta we gotta change it we gotta go
we gotta make some content you're gonna
do this and make that first video so
even for me even for someone who's done
five figures of videos
every time like i sit in front of the
camera to make a video
the first one i procrastinate i sit on
it because i'm afraid
and i don't want to disappoint people
so it's totally normal
so if you feel like whatever the thing
is that you want to do
you know you're capable of it you know
in your heart that it's something that
you want to create and then for some
reason you keep stopping you keep
procrastinating you keep staying stuck
that's normal
you're not there's nothing wrong with
you it's not abnormal it's 100 everybody
goes through it
the difference is how quickly can you
shift how can you get unstuck because
most people just stay stuck they stay
constipated
like all this all the stuff that has to
come out that's just not coming out
you're constipated
you stay stuck so how do you do it how
do you shift it here are a couple things
that help me that i hope can help you
number one is is floss the first tooth
take immediate momentum you think about
flossing
it's you know people don't want to floss
i mean i floss i built a habit of
flossing twice a day
most people don't floss
and the concept is just floss one tooth
and once you floss one tooth you'll
floss the rest probably right just get
your running shoes on and go for a walk
and once you're walking you probably do
more than you know the two minutes that
you set yourself into mind like just do
two minutes so for me
is just make the first video
come on evan just record the first video
so i recorded the first video and now
this is my second video in my filming
session
and i'm already feeling better it's like
we're going we're vibing yeah let's do
this is amazing
come on
just get going just just go it's so much
easier to keep the momentum going once
you've built some momentum the hardest
step is the first step the hardest step
is just building that initial momentum
at the beginning once you get going it's
a lot easier to keep going so just start
don't don't make it some big thing
they'll make it some giant endeavor that
you have to go off and chase it's nice
to have big goals and big ambitions and
big dreams
but sometimes they're too big
and then you feel like you can't do it
and you need venture capital and you
need a team and you need all sorts of
things before you can do anything on it
it's great to have that big goal and
what are you gonna do today
to build some kind of momentum
and once you start building up momentum
it's just so much so much so much so
much easier so the challenge for today
is just just find one small simple
easy way to get started
it doesn't have to be amazing it doesn't
have to be great it's just the first
step
once you get your first step it's so
much easier to take the second so that's
one just start building some immediate
momentum number two is change your state
one of the reasons why i like filming in
the car people ask why are you always
filming in your car i like i like being
out i like i like being out of the place
out of my home i like i like energy i
like nature let me see trees and and
sunshine and have people around you know
i like i like that it changes my state
it's it makes it a lot easier for me
to go off and film when i'm by myself so
it's not just
um
me talking to the camera if this feels
more conversational i don't know it's
all it's all just uh a head game
but it feels more i feel like i'm
talking to a friend hello
how you doing i'm evan
it feels
it feels more conversational and natural
for me i like having the sun on my face
you know it just feels better and so
changing your state can be a good way if
you're in a
wherever you're at you know think
whether you're in your bed or in your
car or in your office or the dining room
table you know change your state move
around get up
you want to change the negative thoughts
start moving get up doesn't have to go
work out or do you know 100 jumping
jacks just get up and even get getting
some fresh air getting out of the space
that you're thinking negatively in
really helps just changing your physical
location really really really really
helps i promise you
have you ever had a uh you're thinking
really negatively um you're
procrastinating you're feeling down and
then you go for a walk and you feel
better or even just change your room
or you go to a different part of the
house or you go for a drive and then you
feel better like changing the physical
environment can really help you get out
of that funk that you're in where while
you're in that space you're feeling
stuck and you can't move so change your
physical environment one little bonus
for that is music musical music
is
the fastest way to change your state
so while i was sitting here in the car
for 15 minutes procrastinating and
making these videos
instead of thinking hey i should go
and check in on my team and see how
they're doing underneath like logically
that makes sense like how's my team
doing i'm being a good boss you know
good manager
a good friend i should check in on them
see how they're doing it's going to move
my goals forward of course because if
they're waiting on me for something
right logically all that makes sense
underneath it is just
again the fear that
my videos won't be good enough so i need
to feel productive i need to feel value
valuable to myself i need to feel worthy
so i'm going to spend my time there
instead of making videos right
i should have put on music when that was
happening
instead of going to check out my team
which i didn't do but wanted to
uh
i should have put on some music
like put on some music that makes you
move and you don't have to be the most
expressive dancer or singer just
anything that would get your head
bobbing or your foot tapping or your
knee bouncing just songs that make you
come alive and there's no one perfect
song but whatever song
gets you in the zone
even if you're feeling really low you'll
find yourself like having energy and
moving and it changes your state the
whole point is just to get unstuck and
to start building some momentum towards
what you say is what you want to do
right so music is a fast way to change
your state and then number three is i
would say have play bigger triggers
and play bigger triggers are the things
in your environment that remind you of
who you want to be
the things that you could put up the the
reminders on your cell phone background
on your desktop background the artwork
on your wall
the things that you could put in your
life to remind you of who you want to be
so i'll share a couple from my example
in my office i have five pictures on the
wall and they all tell a different story
remind me of who i want to be i've got
steve jobs on the wall who reminds me to
be a visionary i've got ap giannini on
the wall who's my favorite entrepreneur
of all time and he reminds me to to
believe in
um in the little guy and what i'm trying
to do i've got my parents on the wall
who remind me to believe in myself i've
got howard schultz on the wall who
reminds me to stand for something
important i've got kanye on the wall to
remind me that the time is now that i
have to go do something now to be
the greatest meme and
those pictures i picked with intention
and when i walk into my office they're
there and they remind me and i don't
have to do anything you know you set it
up once and it reminds me it reminds you
of who you want to be i walk in the
office there's my parents looking back
at me and telling me to believe in
myself
the clothes that you wear right i wear i
wear this is my believe hoodie i feel
like i'm batman i tell myself when i put
this on i'm batman i'm a superhero going
to work
fighting
the crime of lack of belief
[Laughter]
right and and so just somebody commented
on my hoodie yesterday you're always
wearing you're always on brand you're
always wearing your hoodie it's like
it's not just
it's not just when i show up to make
videos this is this is this is what i
wear because i'm a
i'm a superhero going to work and when i
put this on in the morning it's like i'm
i'm i'm batman going to work or uh
you know police officer going to work
it's like this is this is what i do
and
i'm a lot more
for me
productive and ambitious and bold
when i'm wearing this compared to when
i'm in my pajamas
until there's a conscious choice to say
okay what do i want to wear
and so the artwork on my wall the
background on my cell phone the computer
screen background the
the
things that i wear right play bigger
triggers
that you ideally just set it up once
and then it reminds you it's okay there
it is there's my trigger again there
there it is this is who i want to be
this is who i want to be this is who i
want to be i'm around the things that
make me
remember what i'm trying to do because
your brain will trick you
to stay small your brain will trick you
to stay stuck your brain will trick you
to say yeah you you can't do that and
here's all the reasons why
and you believe those reasons you
believe those reasons we're really
you're just afraid i'm just afraid i'm
afraid that we're not good enough we're
afraid that we're going to be judged
we're afraid of disappointing people
we're afraid of not being loved we're
afraid
that
we're going to be seen and going to be
made fun of you know we're just afraid
at the end of the day you me everybody
we're just we're just afraid that the
reason why you're stuck is you're afraid
and so when you can learn
to catch those feelings
and when you can learn to uncover those
feelings and switch them
say you know what
i'm going to change my environment i'm
going to change my state i'm going to
change what i'm listening to i'm going
to change what i'm wearing i'm going to
change my mind and i'm going to go do
the thing to start building momentum
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum
the only thing you're missing is
momentum you've got a great heart a
great soul a great idea your idea is
worthy you're doing it for the right
reasons you want to serve you can do
this you can be in a totally different
place in six months and 12 months you
can it's possible you can your mission
is worthy and noble and should happen
and you're the one to do it you you're
the one to do it
and it's not that you're not good enough
and it's not that you're not capable and
it's not that you can't do it at some
point you just don't have the momentum
momentum
you're just missing momentum
and so the next time you feel stuck
procrastinating not good enough
know that you can do it
and that all you need to do is take that
first step
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
recent one-on-one with gary vaynerchuk
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i'm talking about
something that the world thinks is a
contradiction i don't understand why
anybody
should ever verbally dress down
an employee
in a meeting ever